miss quad season nine feeling fine and
you are back where you belong full time
full time
other than correct how does it feel to
be back in that intro with the
[Laughter]
you know what it feels great to be back
in the intro in my rightful position
[Music]
i think
uh last season definitely
lend it to the valium which i bring
brought to the show in which in which i
bring to the show and i think um
me not being presents present was
definitely fail taking that step
back
did it feel like the right choice in
hindsight or do you wish you had been
full-time last year because you were
going through some things also
no i don't wish i was full-time last
year
at all um things happened the way they
were supposed to i think it afforded me
the opportunity to kind of have some
time to take care of some things that i
needed to put a button on and then not
only that i think it allowed uh the
network to see my true value and worth
in which i bring to the table
in reference to the project married to
medicine well stepping into this season
you're also kind of in a new season of
life they're lining up a little bit what
was your mentality going in to being
back around this group so much again
you know what the mentality i had was
honey yes some of you girls are going to
be upset but the doll is bad fix your
face
and then when cameras went down
did you still have that same energy or
are you bringing a different energy at
the end of this oh no i keep the same
energy
yeah we keep it consistent yeah we're
gonna keep it very consistent
uh we're getting to see you in i will
borrow a word from marlo hampton monty
mode
with little mason scene stealer
superstar mason ah everyone says it
about amazing faces okay i don't like
that school bus
why not because because i'd be yelling
like maniacs on that thing uh-uh not
maniacs he is hilarious he's so smart
he's a brilliant kid what's it been like
to kind of embrace that role and really
take that on and live in that with him
you know it's been a great opportunity
for me to stand in the absence of my uh
younger brother who recently passed
which is mason's father of course uh
family has always been first with me
this is just what has been ingrained in
me instilled in me and i've always felt
like i am my family's keeper and i'm
responsible for them so
um it was it was a no-brainer when it
came down to
um
us just coming together as a family to
see what was the next best move uh for
mason and both uh his mom and i uh
thought that georgia was a good place
for the both of them and she too lives
here in in in the area
and we wanted to provide him with the
best school system and and any resources
that i have and and
that's just kind of what we did it was
just a no-brainer
so his mom is still involved in his life
oh very much so and you'll be seeing her
this season as well oh that'll be nice
to see because i think there are some
questions there of how does this all
work yeah it just works like a village
in the house got mason we've got your
mom what's the dating situation like
quad right now
the david is still dating miss ma'am is
still dating now my floor plan is lovely
and i have my own wings so i'm okay so
the privacy is there but still i am
mindful that i do have a young mind
that's with me and i need to make sure
he understands how a woman is to conduct
herself and
so he needs to always have an image of
stability and i want to make sure that
uh that i provide that your love life
seems to be a topic of conversation
within this group baby won't the people
want to know huh i mean maybe even to a
salacious end there's a rumor about
quora 2 that she slept with one of her
contractors anything you want to clear
up for the people what i do pam he said
he's on the contrary honey
that's what i did
and i paid him coins honey coins do you
understand what i'm saying why your
transfers now i wouldn't sleep with
anybody who i have paid okay
i'm just saying
nothing it kissed my ass it wasn't about
getting through to heavenly it was about
getting heavily getting heavily back for
everything that she had done and said
about everyone and to everyone we are in
the middle of this heavenly intervention
did you have any idea
that that's what you were gonna walk
into that night well if you go back to
the episode i literally i picked the
scene i said oh okay this is what we're
doing oh okay you oh
okay
the deal is i'm very diplomatic in this
approach because i see both sides of the
coin as a friend i don't think it's fair
for you to jump on any social media or
whatever platform and dog out your
friends uh especially say some things
that's completely not true about them i
will be dealing with that with heavenly
moving forward um i really had my pencil
and my pen out thinking i was gonna deal
with it down to the intervention but
that didn't happen yeah so i that screen
grab went around the twitter sphere of
you taking notes during it what were you
writing down every damn thing that was
coming out of her mouth because i wanted
to address it okay you wanted to make
sure that you didn't miss anything so
that when
if an intervention was actually going to
happen you could make points about what
you saw correct correct
so that was the one thing and on the
other side of that the other side of the
coin is that um i don't believe that
if you're really trying to get to the
core of the reason as to why someone is
doing something and i think you need to
take more of a tender approach i think
you need to take more of a empathetic
approach um and you need to really do
that with
people individuals that this particular
person trusts and so
when all that happened when i initially
saw what was going on i knew that hadler
was going to flee i knew she was gonna
flee oh this was too much oh she's out
of there you understand i knew that that
was gonna happen and then um
secondly i just i felt that
the whole laughing component she was not
laughing because it was funny i don't
think that heavenly was laughing because
she thought that oh my god this is
hilarious no that was a very nervous
laugh she had a club what is naked out
there but i say she sleep sleeping
married william
[Music]
are you kidding me
[Music]
it was more like oh my god i'm caught
red-handed
they got me what what do i do how do i
get out of this so i'm just gonna laugh
my way out of this because
it's uncomfortable for me to have to
deal with it and that's how i felt i
believe wholeheartedly that's what the
laugh was about the intervention moment
never actually came to fruition we got a
get up flea and chaos so where do things
go from fear they get worse
how much it works
it gets explosive very much so
yeah do you think heavenly and contessa
can have a friendship moving forward no
there's no trust there i think that
relationship has run its course and i
don't foresee them getting close again
ever
could they be cordial absolutely will
they ever divulge any personal thing
contestant is never listen i contestants
never probably gonna ever tell anyone
on this particular show
while on the show anything about her
personal life i think those days are
over well that kind of takes me back to
last season's reunion you spoke up on
contessa's behalf contesta has moved
forward with filing
you filed
she filed for separation
was that something you guys had
discussed before that happened or was
that a decision you made in the moment
no i don't make decisions in a moment
about other people's relationships i
actually had spoken with contessa and as
a friend i wanted to kind of
show support for her but
at the same time
it was it was it was pretty challenging
for me but i you know this is what she
asked me to do
uh and i and i happily obliged because i
wanted to show my support for her but
ultimately i do support the metcalfes i
do support their marriage you know and i
i'm happy to say i think they're doing
better much better in being
close to contessa close to heavenly are
you able to have those independent
relationships and not have them cross
over or do you ever feel like you're in
a tough spot
no because i'm not really gonna let one
say too much about the other that's out
of line you know what i mean uh and
everyone i think everyone knows that
about me i in this particular case i'm
very diplomatic
because i care for both of them i think
both of them are beautiful smart women
um and i i don't have an issue with
contessa and i don't have an issue with
heaven i have to i do have to deal with
heavenly about some things but in terms
of having an overall
issue with her i don't
so heavenly's point of view on the
youtube channel is anything i'm saying
is
made for public consumption i'm
commenting on things that are already
out in the world
do you think that's true or is she
fudging the line there and sharing
something well now she the things that
in reference to me now i can only speak
to miss quad okay i'm just going to
speak to miss quad because i know miss
quad personally you know what i mean
um
intimately personally you're very
rehearsal i don't miss quite personally
so the thing that she said that she said
i had fillers i don't have fillers you
know what i mean i have never had any
augmentation on my body uh minus the
surgery that i had to get my fibroids
removed uh my body is given to me by
jesus thank you lord via my mother so i
all of those things were lies and uh the
whole uh comment about me uh what did
she say sleeping with marry men or
sleeping with the contractor yeah that's
a no for me too so uh that will be
something that we will definitely deal
with
for sure
do you think anyone is overly sensitive
about the things heavenly has said or is
everyone's reaction warranted
uh
now hamlet has said something
let's just keep it real you know and i
mean we it's out there and he actually
saw that she said it and we know that we
can't tell people how to feel so i can't
say overly sensitive i can say that
these are things that make them feel uh
hurt and and sad and uh it angered them
yeah why did things get so tense between
you and i am an american simone
yes american honey i hope you are
american girl but if you are gonna drive
me i'm not with you
because this is america it's
understandable get to choose who i talk
with
every day in america it's amazing
you know what that was that was so you
know what i just think samoa was just
trying to have a moment because that's
just like the contagious chaos of like
everybody's screaming so let's scream at
each other
no
but i thought that that was hilarious
and i was like well what the hell does
america got to do with anything right
now
i don't have that but nobody i don't
want to this is a miracle
thankfully
the randomness of that comment broke the
tension everybody was just like okay we
have all we all need to break for the
night cameras go down it was so funny
i'm still laughing at it you know even
now it's so funny there's still a lot of
season to watch we have just barely
scratched the surface of season nine um
we're gonna meet audra this group is
unpredictable
you gotta have your head like on a
swivel why are we always making special
privileges for you it's not special
privileges she's choosing not to i'm
sorry you're not a good attorney what do
we need to know let me tell you
something uh audra is a very smart young
lady and what i think you know people
always try to say oh well the newbies
just trying to get in there and they're
just trying to create an issue and
trying to be seen and trying to get a
moment uh not in this case with audra
and as the season progresses you will
see that toya consistently takes digs at
audra
from her
work ethics and how how good she is
as an attorney to the clothes that she
wears on her back so toya is just
consistently picking at this girl and
she was fed up and then you have to take
the seven liens that you have filed so
where are we at we are in the negative
pick enough she'll get picked that back
and it seemed like she came with some
facts in that picking she came with big
fats she came well researched we were on
some systems that cost some money to
access to get some information
indeed but we have to remember that she
is a real estate attorney
you have real estate issues you should
probably not mess with the real estate
attorney
i'm just saying i mean my train of
thought in what's still to come what are
you most excited to relive yourself or
have the fancy
oh
what i'm most excited about and i think
that everyone is going to love
our girls trip to las vegas hands down
this was one of the best trips yet this
girl's trip i really feel like the
ladies truly
let their hair down honey and they got
wild the people got wild the ladies were
very wild honey
baby
things happened to me
oh my god
and then on the flip side
anything you're bracing for impact for
anything you'll be watching through
covered fingers over your eyes that
you're nervous to relive
uh not me
not me i'm ready to deal with it all in
fact i may have a good time dealing with
it should anybody be nervous
a lot of people should be nervous
yeah if you have my name in your mouth
in any type of negative way you should
probably be on pins and needles and be
nervous you should probably be shaking
in your boots right now
and you'll come and collect those girls
at the reunion snatching edges like you
always do
[Music]
you